the first face-to-face meeting between
President Trump and top Democrats since
the impeachment inquiry began did not go
smoothly the Democrats walked out
yesterday claiming the president
insulted House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
during a briefing for congressional
leaders on the deteriorating military
situation in Syria the president tweeted
this photo from the meeting showing a
moment of confrontation between the
speaker and the president
Weijia Jiang is at the White House we
shot that trig what triggered the blow
up oh good morning Anthony Democrats say
president Trump lost his cool and was
visibly shaken up because the House
overwhelmingly passed a resolution
condemning his decision to pool those US
troops out of Syria the White House is
painting a very different picture and
blamed Democratic leaders for leaving
early so they could come out here and
whined to the press instead of work with
their colleagues Democratic leaders say
they stormed out of the White House
after President Trump pounced on House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi
when he started calling Speaker Pelosi a
politician I said I wish you were
politician mr. president never have I
seen a president treat so
disrespectfully a co-equal branch of the
government of the United States the
president was a meltdown sad to say
Democrats say the president called out
see you at the polls as they walked out
Republicans said Pelosi warned the
president to watch what we do after the
meeting mr. Trump tweeted a photo of the
confrontation with the caption nervous
Nancy's unhinged meltdown seemingly
unbothered Pelosi responded by making
the photograph the background shot of
her Twitter profile she storms out of
another meeting
trying to make it unproductive lawmakers
on both sides have slammed President
Trump for puling US troops out of Syria
leaving Kurdish allies to fight the
Turkish military alone I want to express
my gratitude to the Kurds I'm sorry that
we're that we are where we are the Kurds
are much safer right now but the Kurds
know how to fight to suggest the Kurds
are safer is really delusional Trump
Ally Senator Lindsey Graham repeatedly
called it the biggest mistake of his
presidency it will be to our shame and
our national security detriment and a
trump will own the reemergence of Isis
and if you think they're just coming
after Europe and they don't represent a
threat the United States you're sadly
mistaken the White House press secretary
described President Trump as measured
factual and decisive in the meeting
Democrats say they kept pressing him to
hear what his plan is in Syria he
responded to keep Americans safe
to which they pointed out that is a goal
Tony and not a plan
all right strong words from Lindsey
Graham there we should thank you very
much